[Music]
Matt Damon speaks out on the Harvey
Weinstein scandal I knew he was a
womanizer you know I wouldn't want to be
married to the guy but like I'm not you
know it's not my business really but
this level of criminal sexual predation
is not something that I ever thought
would what's going on absolutely not
while Matt claims he was unaware of
Weinstein's history of inappropriate
behavior towards numerous women the 47
year old actor says he knew about an
incident where the director allegedly
sexually harassed a Gwyneth Paltrow back
when they co-starred in Weinstein's the
talented mr. Ripley I knew the story
about Gwyneth from Ben because he was
with her after Brad and so I knew that
story but I was working with Gwyneth
with Harvey you know on Ripley I never
talked to Gwyneth it's been Toby but I
knew that they had come to whatever
agreement or understanding that they had
come to she had handled it and she was
you know the first lady of Miramax and
he treated her incredibly respectfully
always it's so infuriating that this was
allowed to go on as long as it did
George Clooney also opened up about
Weinstein's behavior you know Harvey
would talk about women that he you know
gone out with and I didn't really
necessarily believe that cuz to believe
that would believe some bad things about
actresses that I know and like and I
didn't really buy into that but I will
say that somebody knew
[Music]